[Music]
he is ruthless he is tenacious
he is ingenious he's a media tycoon
who created a global empire worth more
than 80 billion dollars
he has an extraordinary passion for the
media business he is in it
24 hours a day seven days a week he eats
sleeps
and drinks it success does not come
quickly or easily
in the media news corps rubert murdoch
is a modern day press baron
who rules newspapers and magazines
television networks and cable channels
film studios and satellite systems often
reflecting the message
of their provocative and polarizing
chairman his editors know what rupert
wants
and they're quite happy to carry that
out for more than 50 years murdoch has
been building his kingdom one piece at a
time
along the way attracting a firestorm of
controversy rupert murdoch
is the embodiment of evil it's no longer
the respected paper that it once was
and sparking bitter rivalries it's a
newspaper war
there's always someone who must die in
order for you to live
and rupert is good at that battle
because he can take more pain than
anybody else
those battles have taken his company
from the heights of success
to the brink of collapse and back rupert
is mainly interested in power
you could almost say a megalomania to
own as much as he can to influence as
much as he can to be the biggest and
best that ever was or ever will be
rupert murdoch has been called many
things even on his own network
i'm rivet murdoch the billionaire
tarrant and this is my skybox
if you're rupert murdoch prove it
[Music]
murdoch's presence in film television
and print
is felt in nearly every part of the
globe rupert murdoch
is what god meant when he created a
media executive
he has all the attributes that a media
executive is supposed to have he has
vision
he has guts he'll take a risk he'll go
to the edge
his empire started with a small
newspaper in australia
and became one of the biggest media
companies in the world
with over 150 newspapers international
television operations
and a movie studio news corp pulls in
yearly revenues of some 32 billion
dollars
the man who controls so much of what we
see in the media
declined to be interviewed about his own
life here
he has never been one to hide his
political agenda i would say supported
the bush policy right in the middle east
we've been very critical of his
execution
or disguise his ambition extremely
ruthless
knew what he wanted and nothing would
stop him from getting what he wanted
and i think that's probably been his
hallmark the whole of his life
the beginning and the core of his empire
the newspaper
michael wolff is the author of the man
who owns the news
this is a man who grew up in the
newspaper business found success in the
newspaper business
literally loves the newspaper business
i've seen him read a newspaper and it's
a physical act
it's as physical as literally making
love to a woman
that obsession was in his genes rupert
murdoch was born on march 11
1931 to prominent newspaper man sir
keith murdoch
and his wife lady elizabeth murdoch he
grew up on the family farm outside
melbourne australia
he was sent to the exclusive g-long
boarding school
near melbourne i don't know whether i
enjoyed it or not i didn't think so at
the time but looking back on it
most of my memories are certainly happy
ones but he felt out of place surrounded
by the children of melbourne's elite
andrew butcher is the former senior vice
president of corporate affairs and
communications for news corp
rupert was definitely from a privileged
background but
his father didn't own the business that
he worked in he managed it
rupert always saw himself as an outsider
he thrived on that
it gave him a competitive edge
he would set himself apart further when
he went on to oxford
where his attraction to communist
philosophy earned him a nickname
red rupert that was probably the product
of
a young man's rebellious spirit i'm sure
he would have rebelled against his
parents where he could and against his
parents values just like most
young people mungo mccallum was a young
journalist in australia who would later
work with murdoch
i think a lot of what drove rupert
murdoch particularly in those days
was the desire to live up to his
father's reputation
it was a fraught relationship i think
his father was
quite remote hard to get a kind
word out of a way a lot but in
hindsight rupert has enormous amount of
affection for his father all for what he
attained
and determination to make his father
proud
in october of 1952 while at oxford
murdoch received the devastating news
that his father had died at age 67
after having battled heart problems and
cancer
returning home he found his mother under
pressure from his father's colleagues to
sell off their newspaper holdings
rupert was appalled at the way that his
mother was treated
and the lack of respect for his father
after his death
part of the estate at risk of being sold
was the adelaide news
a struggling tabloid with a circulation
of only seventy five thousand
a few months after finishing at oxford
murdoch moved home to australia
to take control his fingerprints were
soon on every part of the operation
he was extremely hands-on i know from my
experience of his editing skills that
they were
they were certainly the equal of
anyone's in 1958
he made his first foray into a different
medium
television with channel 9 a small local
outlet
peter chernin is the former president
and chief operating officer of news corp
i think one of the things that people
don't remember is you know rupert owned
a television network back in australia
as early as i think the late 50s early
60s so and it's sort of one of the
things that brought him here you know he
had been buying
uh rerun rights and rights to movies
from american studios and from
uh american networks the station's value
took off murdock was soon buying up a
variety of local newspapers
including the daily mirror a popular
lowbrow sydney tabloid
but murdoch's goal was to start a
national newspaper
in 1964 he launched the australian
he was told from the beginning that it
couldn't possibly work
that the distances were too vast that
there was not enough
national advertising to sustain it he
was told that he wouldn't be able to get
the staff for it because no
good journalist would want to work on a
paper which was so clearly doomed to
failure
the paper had a liberal stance right
from the start
and the man in charge was ever present
if it was running through the office up
and down
virtually every night and it wasn't
uncommon for rupert to stride into the
paper quite late at night about 10
o'clock around deadline
time usually wearing a bright yellow
raincoat
and occasionally confused with a cleaner
by one of the staff who didn't know him
very well
murdoch's hands-on command of his papers
established itself
early i get very involved in the
newspapers themselves on the other hand
i think that i give my editors
tremendous freedom at age 25 murdoch
married and had a daughter
prudence the marriage ended in divorce
after 11 years
in 1967 he married his second wife
anna torv over the next five years they
had three children
elizabeth lachlan and james what's
important to murdoch
is his family and his company i actually
think those things are absolutely
connected in his
in his mind as he matured murdoch grew
more conservative
in his views rupert became more and more
captive
of the business community in sydney
and when rupert went to the cruising
yacht club the other members were always
taunting him about oh how's that red rag
of a paper of yours going now
rupert and this i think eventually got
to him
rupert i think is mainly interested in
power
you could almost say megalomania to
own as much as he can to influence as
much as he can to be the biggest and
best that ever was or ever will be by
the late 1960s
rupert murdoch had landed on another
continent and into one of the world's
most competitive markets
and the very definition of old
establishment
london's fleet street he ran
headlong into the notorious media tycoon
robert maxwell
it became murdoch's david against
maxwell's goliath
murdoch established a pattern of going
to battle against his
well-known competitors you can look at
rupert's
business strategy as newspaper strategy
it's a newspaper war there's always
someone who must die
in order for you to live with a one-two
punch he out-maneuvered maxwell
and purchased the popular and gossipy
news of the world
and later the faltering daily the sun
he remade it revived it built it
in a very short time into a powerhouse
readership was largely men involved a
kind of combination of sports
sex scandal a little bit of politics
and the page three girls topless girls
and
and it worked charlie beckett is a media
analyst at the london school of
economics
i think the sun newspaper love it
or loathe it and millions of people love
it and buy it has had
an extraordinary cultural impact both
for good if you like and for
evil and it's delivered in a style
that's engaged the public
in some very real issues and it's been
of course a fantastic commercial success
now murdoch set his sights on a new
world to conquer
america he was never comfortable in
australia and never comfortable
in the in the uk but he arrived here and
almost immediately he thought this is
home
that home became new york in 1973
rupert murdoch and his family settled on
new york's affluent upper east side
he was hungry to expand but to break
into the u.s
market he had to settle for a small
regional paper
he buys a paper in san antonio texas
he bought it because he could afford to
buy it
next murdoch wanted a national presence
so he started a paper that would become
the star hoping to compete with the
lurid national enquirer
the star struggled to shine tabloids are
sold in supermarkets in america
which means that they have to be for
women not men
and it was never a wholly successful
experiment for him
nevertheless he later sold a recharged
star
to the parent company of the national
enquirer for 400 million dollars
but it was a fading liberal tabloid the
new york post
that captured his imagination
in 1976 he handed over 30 million
dollars for the paper
a few weeks later in the face of
employee opposition
he added the new york magazine company
for 7.5 million dollars
the purchase included the liberal
village voice
it would be hard to think of a
publication less
likely to belong to rupert murdoch than
the village voice
the voice returned a handsome profit
eight years later
murdoch sold it for 55 million dollars
murdoch was now on the map in new york
he was featured on the cover of time
magazine in january of 1977
as king kong towering over the city
grasping its most
influential publications including his
pet project
the post martin singerman is the former
publisher of the new york post
the paper had been allowed to really
dwindle and die if you will
rupert murdoch invested more in the
publication both in terms of
of money substantially in in people
we invested in presses a year and a half
later
to bring color to the newspaper added
pages
and did the things that you you would do
in order to make a more
substantial publication murdoch's
instincts revived the paper with
attention-grabbing headlines
inside news of the day combined with
juicy gossip
sports coverage horoscopes and games no
headlines sell papers but
for the long run when you have a daily
newspaper there has to be substance
because people aren't going to buy
once look at it and find nothing so it
really is a two-step
process the post became a
new york favorite financially it was a
disaster
losing millions of dollars every year
ron grover is a business journalist i
don't really think rupert's in it to win
uh in in terms of of the bottom line he
likes the idea that it gives him a place
at the table he likes the idea
that he can get his position out there
he likes the idea that he gets entre
to politicians by 1980 rupert murdoch
was a major player in the new york media
scene
he continued to claim he gave his
editors tremendous freedom
but that message didn't always make it
to the staff river wrote headlines
shaped stories dictated the leagues and
stories rupert was everywhere
somebody said to him mr murdock there
seems to be
a contradiction you said that
you allow your editors to
run the newspaper and he said
there's no contradiction i just know the
editors i hire there's rupert and then
there are the people under him
he likes to hire people who are grateful
to him for having been hired
he likes to hire people whose loyalty he
can count on
he does not like to hire people who
might compete with him
might feel that they are on the same
footing as him
the way that he has influence and
control
through his news organizations is not
really by
screaming down the phone there is more
of a sense
that his editors they know what rupert
wants
and they're quite happy to carry that
out
what rupert wanted soon began to play
out in a decade-long spending spree
in 1981 he bought the prestigious times
and the sunday times of london
back in the states he scooped up the
boston herald and the chicago sun times
and once again he was met with a revolt
four top executives of the sun time
said they were resigning including
publisher james hull
syndicated columnist mike royko has
taken a leave of absence
i i i would never work for a newspaper
with the kind of
york san antonio
they're trash and none of that phased
murdock
he wouldn't stop at newspapers in 1985
he does the deal to buy 20th century fox
a deal of quintessential importance
because what it is is a crossover
here's a man who's in the publishing
business and now he's buying a movie
studio
he paid former oil man marvin davis 250
million dollars for a 50
stake in the studio he had a hard time
getting the first 50
from marvin davis but he was able to
pick the other 50
up for the relative bargain of 325
million dollars
so he took full ownership of the 20th
century fox film studio
a multi-billion dollar asset now for
about half a billion dollars
he once told me that the movies are the
the sizzle you need the sizzle when you
have the rest of the
of the media empire and and so he knows
he needs it because of what
it's what brings creative people to the
enterprise
that sizzle could also singe especially
in the notoriously risky
multi-million dollar movie business one
of the great things about rupert which
is
in a crisis he is the coolest calmest
and
if he supports you and he believes in
you he'll back you all the way to the
wall you know he's not a guy who sort of
starts worrying about it or starts going
and ringing his hands
if he believes in you and you're being
straight with him
and you convince him of the
appropriateness of your decision he's
the best guy you could ever want in the
foxhole with you
murdoch was anxious to expand his
enterprise by buying into the united
states television market
but he faced a serious obstacle there's
an fcc rule that says you must be a
united states citizen
to own a tv station and rupert who's
ever the pragmatist
decided well if that's what it takes i'm
going to become a us citizen
on september 4th 1985 rupert murdoch
took the oath to become a naturalized
american
sir rod eddington is the former ceo of
british airways
and a close friend when rupert gave up
his australian citizenship to take
american citizenship
there was some criticism of him for
doing that but the business is based in
america its major market is in america
and he's chosen to live in america
so it's not as if he embraced american
citizenship
only for the purposes of being a media
baron in america he's chosen to make his
life in america
and his ultimate mark murdoch had
a master plan he paid metro media's john
kluge up to two billion dollars to buy
television stations in six major markets
they formed the nucleus of what would
become fox television network
there was abc nbc cbs and there was
no room on the dial for another network
well suddenly rupert comes along and
he's
able to launch a fourth network he
could see that there was great scope for
a network that attracted
younger viewers and a more diverse
range of viewers but the new network
badly misfired with their high profile
debut
this is the bleep button we are going to
be live and that means
no bleep the late show starring joan
rivers
failed miserably against the unshakable
johnny carson
for the young team at fox it was a big
lesson
garth ansir is the former president of
fox television
no one had started a network since the
1950s understanding what would make
a network differentiated from nbc abc
cbs which were really the real
competitors then
was something that we had to discover by
trial and error i mean it seems obvious
in retrospect that oh yeah if you run
when
cbs is running you won't succeed fox set
about attracting top talent
like series creators james brooks and
stephen cannell
it was a combination of some creative
freedom
certainly more than the other networks
we're going to give them but we gave
larger orders
we would go directly to series and some
some of that was just
because we had to we had only a year to
get the network up and running
from from scratch beating the odds with
a host of shows that countered the
competition
the fourth network began to register in
the ratings
[Music]
twenty-one jump street young cop show
married children
you know irreverent family show i mean
the working title of
married children was not the cosby's and
living color and all those things
became much more i get it that has to be
different from what you can get
on the other channels and nothing was
more different
than the show that would change
everything the single biggest turning
point was the simpsons
ow ow
would it hey what's with this ow
rupert always loved setting the network
schedule more than anything he was like
a kid in a candy store
and i used to joke because he'd jump up
and start putting squares up on the
board and sort of say how's that and we
go well that's really not
not that good you go okay okay then you
move it and put something else up
but rupert jumped up at one point and
and took simpsons
and put it on thursday night against the
cosby show you know he's talking about
putting this
tiny little show that we're just getting
started up against the number one show
on television
and at first honestly we all thought he
was crazy we said we can't do that we'll
get killed we'll get annihilated
and he kept saying you know trust me i
think it'll work that move of
the simpsons against cosby was a hundred
percent rupert's idea
while rupert murdoch was expanding into
american television
an ocean away in london he triggered a
revolt from the powerful british press
unions
this should be the print capital of the
world and all that work has gone out
because of the activities of the london
print unions
in an effort to automate his newspaper
production murdoch moved it from fleet
street
to a plant in the dockside area of
london called whopping
the efficient new plant needed fewer
workers to make it run
fifty five hundred fewer workers murdoch
planned to lay them all off as the
former general secretary of the british
printing union
sogat baroness brenda dean negotiated
with murdoch to try and save jobs
he'd taken the view understandably he
wasn't going to move out
of fleet street with the old work
practices into a new plant
that didn't need the old work practices
what he wanted was an extremely radical
deal on
the employment practices in the company
and he wasn't going to get it
we were still prepared to negotiate and
he listened
and he said at the end of it the music
has changed but the dance remains the
same
unknown to brenda dean murdock had
already made a secret deal with the
electricians union to run the plant
and quickly move forward with a trial
print run
and then of course once we knew that and
once we knew they were running trial
runs
then for the first time as general
secretary i said to our people
stop take strike action tonight
[Music]
received support from an old friend
margaret thatcher
who favored management over unions
he had backed the conservative thatcher
when she was a candidate for prime
minister
and it was paying off mrs thatcher's
government
passed legislation and in the news
international dispute the whopping
dispute
as it became known that
what was known as the anti-union
legislation became a key factor
in ensuring that rupert murdoch achieved
what he wanted to
thousands came out to support the
protests but the demonstrations
would take a violent turn
whopping was called fortress whopping
because it really was there was security
essentially a a murdoch militia was
called out
and and he was demonized we did have
some pretty awful
stuff there i mean i saw some of my
members beaten up by
police violence did arrive on the scene
there's no doubt about that
and it was something that we tried to
control and sometimes
we couldn't with the help of thatcher
murdoch crushed the unions
and his plant at whopping was soon
roaring ahead
he took a big gamble on this occasion
and it took a long time getting there
and it was extremely destructive
for the company and his reputation in
the uk
but he got what he wanted in the end he
was
the boogeyman the guy who broke labor's
back
this turns out to be a seminal moment
in not only the history of labor but in
the history of modernity itself
you know he said this is not reasonable
this is not logical
progress dictates that we change the
rules
undaunted murdoch's shopping spree
continued
in 1988 he shelled out three billion
dollars to acquire
the annenberg magazine empire that
included 17
the racing form and tv guide murdoch's
shocking price was the highest ever paid
for a publishing company
but that same year he was tripped up by
federal regulations
prohibiting ownership of a newspaper and
a television station in a single market
as a result murdoch was temporarily
forced to sell his beloved new york post
he was able to buy it back years later
for 25 million dollars
after obtaining a special waiver he's
kept the post alive
because he wants it alive no one else in
in news corporation wants the new york
post alive
save for rupert and the people who work
at the post
it just makes no no economic sense
undiminished murdoch reached for the sky
literally
his next big gamble was on satellite
television
david hill is the senior executive vice
president of 21st century fox
for him to start sky television
up against a hugely funded
establishment satellite platform
called british satellite broadcasting
was
one of the greatest gamblers of all time
nearly nearly bankrupted the company
that heralded this explosion
of television throughout europe and the
rest of the world in 1990
skye merged with british satellite
broadcasting to form
b sky b murdoch maintained 39 percent of
the company
but the return on his investment was in
a downward spiral
b sky b was hemorrhaging money and his
spending spree
had put murdoch dangerously in debt with
creditors
fortunately 145 banks decided to give
him more time
however one bank in pittsburgh refused
and threatened to call in a 10 million
loan
the way he had sort of set up this
covenant of of of banks
is that if one demanded the loan
that they all all of the loans came due
there was a desperate 11th hour call
from murdoch to the bank in pittsburgh
that brought his company back from the
brink of collapse
that was this incredible accomplishment
in which he managed to save the company
he had to sell off parts of it had to
sell the magazines
and had to commit himself to
better business practices the banks have
told him he has to behave himself
he had to restructure nearly 8 billion
in debt it was a near-death experience
for his company
and a defining moment for murdoch he was
deal a minute rupert before this and now
he's
it's much more structured
still in 1993 he was back at the poker
table
he forked over one billion dollars for
the chinese television network
star tv porter bib is an american media
analyst and publisher
rupert murdoch first entered china
through star the the satellite
television network that he
built in hong kong and he had uh
in the early 90s broad and wide access
to
what was essentially a closed media
market for the rest of
western broadcasters but on september
1st 1993
he squandered it murdoch made a speech
in london that inflamed the chinese
government
advances in the technology of
telecommunications
have proved an unambiguous threat
to totalitarian regimes everywhere
the chinese retaliated by banning
private ownership of satellite dishes
and with them murdoch's access to
millions of chinese homes
star tv was under siege
murdoch had to placate the chinese
government so he removed from star a
frequent source of their anger the bbc
he also killed an unflattering book
about china written by the former
governor of hong kong
chinese leadership soon after expressed
admiration
for the gestures and murdoch would
continue from then on to court chinese
officials to expand news corp's often
tense presence in china china is the new
world it's
it is the future and he sees this
earlier and more dramatically than
most people but almost nothing works out
in china his competitor becomes the
chinese government and he can't compete
with the chinese government
rupert murdoch is not much of a sports
fan even so
in december of 1993 he took aim at an
american
obsession football and he scored
with a breathtaking bid of over one and
a half billion dollars
he snatched the rights to nfc games from
cbs
and stunned the wide world of sports
i don't think we've ever done a deal
where we haven't woken up the next
morning with buyer's remorse
and and i i think in a way that's good
because it spurs you to work even harder
for the nfl it could have been a major
fumble
i think the nfl was very brave it was a
gutsy goal on their part because
fox had nothing it was it didn't have a
sports division
so in reality and john madden's great
joke was
we should be glad i saw fox sports where
fox sport
singular they took a huge risk it was
it was like what were they going to do
if we screwed it up
what would have happened if our pregame
show was a shambles
that the set fell apart and then when we
start covering it we're missing
touchdowns we haven't got this the
announcers are wrong
[Music]
and what if he couldn't reach all the
americans who loved football
murdoch didn't blink to get more
eyeballs he invested another
500 million dollars in new world
communications
owned by the savvy investor ronald
perlman
perlman then switched the affiliation of
12 of his prime major market television
stations
to fox it was the biggest realignment of
affiliates in us
broadcast history and a bonanza for the
local stations
the nfl on fox generates over 900
million dollars a year
and has a weekly audience of up to 20
million viewers
murdoch was on a roll but the high
roller wanted to get back to his roots
he's found himself in the television
business which he doesn't like i i don't
think the man has ever watched in a full
hour of prime time tv
but he likes of course the news business
by the mid
rupert murdoch had his sights set on
buying the only 24-hour cable news
network
cnn but its owner ted turner was
contemptuous of murdoch's politics and
pretensions
and the feeling was mutual even call
rupert murdoch
[Applause]
turner eventually and reluctantly sold
cnn
but not to murdoch in 1996
the cable news channel went to time
warner as part of a 7.5 billion dollar
merger with turner broadcasting
murdock had to come up with another
approach he never flinched
and created his own channel to go
head-to-head
with cnn welcome to washington i'm britt
hume
fox news quickly established itself as a
bully pulpit for conservative views
part of the business plan is you
shouldn't compete with cnn
you should go for an audience that is
underserved
and you should do it in a in a way
that's cheaper than
having to send reporters around the
world so we just have opinions
and that's what works and works um
incredibly well
to run it he hired roger ailes a former
consultant to conservative politicians
and republican presidents from richard
nixon to george bush
rupert by his nature is a little
conservative not as conservative perhaps
as roger ailes is but what he liked was
the fact that roger had a plan
for fox news fox news in his early days
lost a lot of money
rupert actually had to pay cable
companies to take it
it was lively controversial and drove
liberals crazy
americans and indeed our foreign allies
who actively work against our military
once the war is underway
will be considered enemies of the state
by me
with a slogan of fair and balanced
former president and ceo of news corp
peter chernin insists that fox news
makes a distinction between the news of
the day
and its talk shows there's news on fox
news
which i happen to believe is actually uh
you know very neutral and moderate and
presented fairly
and then there's talk and opinion shows
which no one ever pretends are news or
factual and
you know bill o'reilly or sean hannity
are clearly
people on the right side of the spectrum
but they've always been presented as
such
the fox news channel has soared past cnn
to become the dominant and most
profitable cable news network in the
united states
but turmoil was brewing in murdoch's
personal life
he divorced his wife anna after 32 years
in 1999.
it was one of the largest divorce
settlements in history
and 68 year old murdoch immediately
married
30-year-old wendy dung a graduate of the
yale school of management and former
vice president of star tv
murdoch's personal life appeared
recharged but less than a year later
he was diagnosed with prostate cancer
but he
perseveres through this and in fact goes
on to have
one child and then another child so at
the age of
70 he has his daughter grace
and then at 72 has his daughter
chloe in 2003
at age 72 rupert murdoch went after yet
another glorious television prize
directv
he had wanted a satellite business in
the united states
for a decade he dealt with the
board of general motors for close to two
years to get a deal done
they eventually sold to rupert
grudgingly and
he finally won directv
his 6.6 billion dollar offer gave him a
34
stake but in a bizarre series of events
only one year later murdoch had to give
it up
while celebrating the returns of george
bush's election in 2004
murdoch overlooked that a huge block of
his company's news corp stock shares
came on the market
in australia american media mogul
john malone not surprisingly was paying
attention
and snatched them up when they were
transferred to the u s market
rupert woke up one morning and said holy
cow this guy owns 16 percent of my
company
he could be dangerous because he
understands that john malone is a
really smart businessman malone's stake
in news corp was now the second largest
after murdoch's to get that chunk of his
company back
rupert had to part with something of
substantial value
to get rid of john malone in the end he
basically had to swap that stake
for direct television i think he might
have wanted to hang on to direct
television it's become a
really really strong operator in
television and rupert doesn't have
a national distribution out he probably
would have liked that
after reclaiming his stock murdoch moved
on with a 2005 purchase of the social
networking site
myspace once again he moved swiftly
and paid a huge price to beat out a
rival this time
viacom's sumner redstone rupert's
experience with the internet is a um
a comic one perhaps from his point of
view a tragic comic one
myspace which was you know he bought for
i don't know i think
somewhat more than 500 million dollars
at one point they thought it was worth
25 billion dollars
and it's you know it's worth scrap now
the effort was considered a disaster
facebook
left myspace in the dust before long
murdock returned to his natural element
refocusing his eyes on one of the most
prestigious and treasured newspapers in
the world
sarah ellison is the author of war at
the wall street journal
and was a former reporter for the paper
when i talked to people about
murdoch and his lust for the wall street
journal even his children said they
couldn't remember a time when he wasn't
talking about the newspaper
the wall street journal and its parent
company dow jones
were owned by the bancrofts a prominent
boston family
who were largely hands-off owners i mean
he's tried to buy the wall street
journal
three times before and they they just
dismiss him um
you know in an incredibly haughty
snobbish way when he first learned about
the divisions within the bancroft family
that had owned the newspaper
for over 100 years that was sort of
blood in the water
murdoch seized the moment and made an
offer the stock was trading for 36
dollars a share
murdoch offered a stunning sixty dollars
a share
jim ottaway is former vice president and
director of dow jones
i certainly remember my reaction which
was shock
feeling of great disappointment that my
life and journalism would end
with the company i worked hard for to
make really great
newspapers at the wall street journal to
have them taken over by
a man who i did not admire as a
newspaper publisher
the staggering offer split the bancroft
family even further
at one point there were children
threatening to sue their parents
if they agreed to sell to murdoch i
thought he would damage the quality of
the wall street journal
if he applied the journalistic
principles that he's
had followed most of his life
which included attacking his enemies
supporting his friends
supporting politicians who could help
him get business advantages
murdoch promised he would maintain the
quality of the paper
and keep the staff are you going to give
full independence to the wall street
journal i'm not saying anymore
i had seen that time and again he had
made promises to owners and then broken
them
very soon he said he would maintain the
standards of the times of london
and guaranteed he wouldn't change the
editor harry evans
and within about a year he'd fired evans
faced with few options
and no offer that was as attractive as
murdoch's six billion dollars
the bancrofts gave in on august first
2007 dow jones entered into an agreement
with news corp that handed murdoch the
wall street journal
i'm privy to to to his incredible
excitement
over acquiring the journal this enormous
feeling of satisfaction
and this rethinking of of his of his own
life
he's going to really spend time at the
journal not everyone was as excited
about that
we're here today to tell everyone to
make sure that they know
that rupert murdoch has bought the wall
street journal
predictably murdoch soon broke the
promises he'd made
and brought in his own people and it was
kind of through the back door that he
managed to deflate the culture and
puncture the egos of the people who were
at the wall street journal in one in one
sort of fell swoop
but murdoch surprised many of his
critics eventually
the wall street journal surpassed usa
today to become the number one daily
paper
in america rupert murdoch
a lion in winter turned 80 in 2011.
after 60 years as the leader of a media
empire
there were questions as to who would
follow him
i think he looks forward to the day when
all three of his children
that are interested in the business work
for him together i think he looks
forward to the day when it's rupert
times
four murdoch bought his daughter
elizabeth's tv production company
shine for nearly 700 million dollars in
2011.
lachlan after an ill-fated career at
news corp
returned to australia to run the ten
television network
murdoch's youngest son james was named
newscorp's new deputy chief operating
officer in new york
i'm very competitive and we're very
competitive
to the extent that where we need to take
market share we're going to go ahead and
take it
that murdock competitive spirit seeped
into the company culture
with devastating consequences
media reports disclosed allegations that
the murdoch-owned tabloid
news of the world tapped the voicemails
of a teenage murder victim
and her family and paid police for
information
i think initially this was seen as
another sordid little journalism scandal
of some journalists who had gone too far
with private investigators
and what we thought was a relatively
limited scandal
turns out to have been a pervasive
systematic abuse
of journalistic power the mobile phones
of celebrities
and politicians were also hacked
so it turns out this phone hacking was a
widespread
and even ubiquitous that it was being
done
to virtually everybody who had the
possibility
of offering any news or gossip
to contain the scandal the 168 year old
news of the world
was shut down in july 2011.
murdoch apologized to a british
parliamentary committee just like to say
one sentence this is the most humble day
of my life
he blamed his staff for misleading him
about the hacking
people i trusted i'm not saying who
i don't know what level they let me down
and i think they
have behaved uh disgracefully and
betrayed
the company and me in the middle of the
hearing
a protester tried to attack murdoch with
a pie
his wife wendy physically defended
the scandal has been damaging and costly
james the heir apparent stepped down as
chairman of b sky b
and news corp has spent over 380 million
dollars in legal fees and settlements
two years after wendy murdoch defended
her husband
rupert murdoch filed for divorce
knocked down but not out murdoch
launched fox sports network
to compete with espn and to placate
shareholders
in june 2013 murdoch split his
six-decade-old publishing business
from the rest of his media empire well
the sky's the limit the new company
officially starts trading today
it's already the largest newspaper
publisher in the united states with a
market value of 8.8 billion dollars
[Music]
rupert murdoch has built a vast and
varied empire
an unrivaled and unstoppable
concentration
of power this is a man who is
extraordinarily powerful
in commercial terms and in political
terms and in cultural terms
[Music]
he's on the level of purse certainly
the defining characteristic of this
thing that we call the press baron
is that constant quest for more and more
power and
that's what we'll remember murdock for
and
for good and and and bad